it is the name synonymous of Vegas Donny
Osmond and our Donnie week continues
here on 8 news now as we pay tribute to
the Las Vegas Entertainer this is
residency in full swing and just
extended he carved out some time to sit
down with me and talk about the early
days
[Music]
beside his brothers when his career
launched at the tender age of five Donny
Osmond quickly Rose to Bane becoming a
teen heartthrob there's one I remember
in London
we're com we're doing a television show
and we went outside and somebody
told all the thousands of fans over on
the front they're in the back and they
come rushing in the back we're running
on the streets
it was like A Hard Day's Night right and
my my brother Alan he's in the lead come
on guys they're gonna attack us and I'm
smiling having a great time and we we
see this little Chinese restaurant and
we duck into the restaurant and hide
under the table and I could see in the
window these hundreds and hundreds of
girls rushing by and I'm thinking this
is awesome but that bubble gum pop was
happening simultaneously as the Osmonds
were trying to find an edgier Groove so
Alan said we got to be tough we got to
show a hard side a tough side so they
added karate to their stage routine and
people laugh when I say yeah Chuck
Norris was my karate teacher from
breaking boards on stage to Breaking
records with hit songs and then
launching Donnie and Marie the cool
thing about working with Marie or family
in general at least my family we all
figured out early on and thanks to my
dad
we learned to get along that certainly
doesn't mean there weren't creative
differences there were times with Marie
so we're not going to do that yes we're
gonna no one remember and the curtain
goes up I'm a little bit country
it was so funny and after the show we
looked at each other and said that was
the best show we've ever done but not
everything has turned out perfectly and
Donnie says that's okay my career has
been up and down and everywhere in
between and this point in my life I
appreciate as I look back the down times
his resiliency and ability to reinvent
himself he says comes from family my dad
had always had a saying anything worth
doing is worth doing well
foreign
and he certainly has done it well and
he's not done yet